she didn't have before I've seen them
[Laughter]
Adam 22 earlier
y'all were hating in that [__] group
chat bro what would you be well I've
sent the text to the group chat like yo
my man's me ain't that crazy right and
y'all were like you actually Googled it
did we all Google it yeah you wild for
that yo because the wildest part that
you thought a 25 inch beat exists
yo he is
on the metric system doing centimeters
what I thought it was that I did think
it was that that's more I didn't think
it was that I did think it was that
because Granny was talking about how it
was 25 inches you cannot believe
everything you posted on Instagram I
didn't believe everything I believed
that okay I thought it was 25
on Facebook
I am one of the old people you know how
many times a week I send my business
manager a text message I get where it's
just like just fill out this passcode
for Facebook and uh don't just pass over
Facebook because your account is about
to be uh overrided or hacked like once a
week I said and they're like this is
Spam don't do it so yes I am that old
person two
he said 25 inches I thought it was maybe
around I thought it was a rough estimate
oh there's 22. my man
22. but I and then I saw it and I was so
let down I was like
it's the worst way to see it yeah you
want it to be three inches dick yeah
she got it like
no I'm not saying the guy's dick ain't
huge is huge but when you think 25
and then it's what do you think it was
nobody thought 25 though yeah that's
what we're tripping on no one thought
25. well you can't say no one because
you're sitting in front of someone who
did okay you see in front of the human
being who thought it was 25 inches
okay me pulling it up yeah we can at
this point
come on what are we doing
that's soft
why is he cooking bro
now let me ask y'all a question
thank you
is it
yeah now go to it hard like it's crazy
to say that but go to it
harder yeah
it's not it was only me and Doug that
saw it but we saw it separate like so
when he hit the group chat with it he's
like you've never seen this I've been
saw it because he knew the name and
everything I don't I've never heard of
this dude I'm black draw
[Laughter]
yeah absolutely
what's that is that one of the black
draws or is that like a Photoshop is
that girl really in Black bra
yeah yeah are you looking at the girl
homo I know about that about that I did
[__] up right there and is he raking
leaves for the hard dick that's crazy
yeah he does a lot of activities yeah
there's a lot of housekeeping evidently
whoa go go to the side to the to the
side go side more down come on go down
right there what's that one Cinderella
see what I mean yeah
all right does the dick point up no oh
wow he got it Alex
I'll explain it
nah miles no yeah dicks are Australian
so that's it hard
it's fine
right
right dude no no no it's it's very big
but I'm thinking 25. yeah I think he
could just be like that he could think
yeah for real yeah I want him to ponder
[__] I'm good on this one what do you
mean
listen okay so should we discuss this
whole Adam 22 thing I think we did right
I think we handled it well we didn't
discuss it yeah
what do you guys think
I mean I don't know that's uh that's a
boundary for me yeah I'm not blown away
by it for him though like if like he
does porn with his girl you know what I
mean like he's a podcaster he's a BMX
dude he's got all these Brands but he
also is a porn star
and so porn stars often like will act in
scenes is the way they see it with other
people so I don't see it as like for him
that crazy
that's the mother
yeah I mean it's crazy
don't come back on
back over here one of
one of us to the Muslim part of the
world
every porn star does it is it weird for
porn stars to do this to do what to like
yeah
thank you y'all all been destined
Destiny done [__] radicalized out of
22. radicalized Mark doesn't Destiny let
his girl do that [__] I don't know bro
that's crazy he's opening
that cut that that's crazy [__] too stop
calling it uh
thing that kids playing yeah it's not
swingers it's you let people [__] your
girl Loki filming is better than not
filming it though because not filming it
you're just doing it for the level oh
you filming you get money off hey hey
you changed my mind with that one I
think it's just a funny point if you
film it I think it's better dude then
you get paid
I don't know because more people don't
know about it
but you know that it was just for the
Love of the Game and that's hard the
bank accounts what I and I haven't I
haven't texted out about this Captain
here say what I know
he's like I got too much money from
to get donkey [__] by some dude yeah
and does that mean
so there look here this is what I
thought it was and I haven't spoken to
Adam about it I I don't even want to
text him about it it's just too [__]
weird but uh but uh my what I thought
this was is you kill a story with a
story I texted you guys this sort of
group I think as well which is like the
story about no jumper was it's falling
apart you had all this people that were
like the uh you know the
they're not staff they're like Talent
they're like on-air Talent all leave
leaves a huge vacuum what's happening
with the identity like what's happening
with the brand is the brand done is it
over and then announces this thing and
then all the conversation is about this
and none of it is about oh my God all
the people that were on the channel have
left it and have gone done their other
things and no jumpers done now people
are being critical of this for sure but
it feels as if the entire internet is
talking about this one phone yeah and if
Adam is cool with it he doesn't care
about the criticism because he's getting
all the views all the attention and he's
pivoting more into something that maybe
is working for him which is hey I like
the porn [__] I don't give a [__] or
make way more money on the porn [__]
than we did the gang [__] so now I'm
completely done with the gang [__] and I
do the porn [__] and I do the podcast
and it's gonna make crazy money it's I
wonder if it's just we're doing one and
then we're quitting the internet
like I I literally wonder if it seems
like he's teeing up the next [__] yeah I
don't think he's doing one of them quick
yeah who knows but yeah if you are
comfortable here's the thing after one
there's uh minimal returns in my
personal opinion diminishing returns
yeah diminishing returns it's like how
many times do you need like once we know
you're okay with someone banging your
wife I don't need to see a third person
bang your wife the big one is the first
one yeah you've either got to go bigger
in size which is like
maybe 24.
that'd be crazy or it's got to be some
kind of like wild collapse he said
something about him and another dude
doing it that is another angle you could
go but I think this is a perfect example
of killing a story with a story
when you said that yeah
just looking away
it's all traditional now you're all
conservative listen what's the big deal
she was into uh adult filmmaking before
they met do you understand you have to
allow her to do this there is a
difference between surfing with a man
and letting that man [__] your wife
you don't know how much he loves surfing
dude so much yeah it's a disconnect
that's it
yeah you never really don't know what
it's like yeah
I'm just trying to say for me they're
the same laughs
they are the same why are you surfing
with with this guy when you could just
be getting [__] by him yeah you might
as well you might as well you might as
well
why are you putting on as little
clothing as possible to get wet with a
man
why don't you just say that to me hey
hey husband I'm gonna go this little
closer
man whoa whoa that sounds crazy be out
of breath
[Music]
[Laughter]
I had to control myself I had to control
myself bro oh my God for real
trying to make me game
I was born in the dark I'm Bane I'm the
bane of this [__] I'm gay yeah
Mark okay [__] out of here
all right come on bring up a topic or
something
um
go business-wise is great for Adam
though oh is that I mean no not wow no
the way it is
Alex we're in a real [__] hot take
over here oh
was it was it good it wasn't that funny
yeah
was it good it's business-wise
wow
where'd you get that one from about
I bet the way they've been marketed it
because they've been don't be mad at him
putting gas
[Laughter]
subscribe to it and then you'll just
have like that large income Revenue
whatever I'm trying
this way
if we're signing up we're signing up for
big black dicks in your wife that's cool
so it's next month if next month I don't
have another big black dick in your wife
I'm tight
I'm commenting bro wow
if I signed up for NBA league passing
you don't give me no games what's the
problem what if it's just Atlanta
surfing with another dude that is the
same thing same thing okay okay if a
black Guy's surfing is surviving I'll be
very surprised
you're gonna be like me in Hawaii
the Dick's the leash
I think I think I think this is going to
be a little
potential problem
keeping up with I agree keeping up with
the standard with the Johnsons I agree
keep up with the justices
or it could be a one-hitter quitter we
out they might be just be catching a
lick or but the worst doesn't happen at
all the worst part she said I was sore
for a few days after oh I mean this is
theater this is them like he is being
very funny yeah
he's being funny yes he got jokes right
he's comments on every page everybody
posted it a bunch it shows the power of
humor too because like the the funnier
he is about it the more okay I feel
about him in the situation or at least
the last unokay I feel about it I feel
less like this I truly okay with it but
okay for him I feel like he doesn't care
I really think he doesn't care yeah I
don't think he does yeah yeah but I also
don't think he has feelings exactly we
told him this when he came on the first
time yeah yeah yeah yeah this confirms
it you have to not have feelings but
what a competitive Advantage you have no
feelings